hi welcome to another cold fusion video
wi-fi is a technology that's almost
universally known to most
it's the go-to method for connecting to
the internet at home
at work or even just a cafe so you might
be surprised to find out that there was
a battle raging between australia
and the united states it was a battle to
determine who received royalties and
credit
for the invention of wi-fi from 2012
u.s consumers were forced to make a 400
plus million
donation to an australian government
agency commonwealth
scientific and industrial research
organization or csiro
most u.s consumers had no idea that this
took place
this was because the cost was hidden in
the huge array of tech products
products like wireless devices and chips
from lenovo
t-mobile at t dell hp
d-link microsoft intel and netgear
all of this happened because of a patent
lawsuit over a key technology in wi-fi
the patent retroactively applies to
practically every wireless enabled
device sold in the us
you may also be surprised to know that
the enabling technology of wi-fi
came from a failed experiment to detect
black holes
it's an interesting story with a few
twists and turns but to understand how
we got here
we must first learn about what wi-fi is
and how it works
you are watching tv
[Music]
so what is wi-fi wi-fi
is a radio wave simply put
radio waves are part of the
electromagnetic spectrum
electromagnetism is one of the four
fundamental forces in nature
without going into too much detail
electromagnetic waves are basically
oscillating disturbances in the
electromagnetic field
it might just be worth spending a second
to talk about electromagnetic waves
it's pretty interesting so the cool
thing is
different frequencies of oscillation
give rise to different forms of
electromagnetic waves
from radio waves of the lowest
frequencies and light
and gamma rays at higher frequencies
starting at radio waves
these waves can be meters to kilometres
long and can be used to listen to the
radio in your car
at frequencies between 87 and 108
million times per second
at about 30 times that frequency these
waves can be used to reliably carry more
information than just sound
wi-fi bluetooth cell phone signals all
use these higher frequencies
these can be 10 centimeters long or
smaller
if we push further increasing the
frequency by about 10
you enter the domain of microwaves
these waves specifically make water
vibrate along with their frequency
billions of times a second
these vibrations of the water molecules
cause heat and when your food contains
water
this heat can warm your whole meal
pushing even further and increasing the
frequency and energy even more
you end up in the infrared domain these
waves are now micrometers long
and can be used for seeing heat patterns
or in your tv remote control
pushing beyond this is visible light and
these waves are now nanometers
this is the only part of the
electromagnetic spectrum that humans can
see
pushing further we enter ultraviolet
light and this is where it starts
becoming dangerous for humans
but ultraviolet light is useful for
sterilizing medical equipment
and also killing bacteria or viruses or
even checking counterfeit money
increase the frequency even more and you
have an even smaller wavelength
and this results in x-rays which can
penetrate your soft tissue
then finally at the highest frequencies
of all you have gamma rays
this is great for killing cancer but it
also fries your healthy cells
x-rays and gamma waves are usually only
brought from radioactive activity in
nature
so in summary wi-fi visible light
and x-rays are all just one in the same
thing just
electromagnetic oscillations but at
different frequencies
as mentioned wi-fi was at the lower end
of the spectrum here's an
artist representation of what wi-fi
waves could look like if you could see
them
so now we know what wi-fi is how does it
work
wi-fi uses electromagnetic frequencies
that oscillate
at 2.4 to 5 billion times a second
these rapid waves can be used to encode
and decode information
wi-fi is simply a protocol for allowing
digital information to be transferred
across
high frequency radio waves this makes it
perfect for high data transfer
applications like the internet
you can think of wi-fi as a very rapid
two-way radio
inside your laptop or phone you've got a
wireless chip that can function
as both a transmitter and receiver of
information in the form of radio waves
you can think of it like little morse
code signals being sent back and forth
to each other but at billions of times a
second
these signals can then be decoded and
interpreted as information
on the other side of your home you'll
likely have a wireless router which has
another transmitter and receiver
connecting both your laptop and router
together on the same radio frequency
band
is what allows them to communicate with
each other and send data back and forth
between each other
data in the form of videos audio
websites and more
in 1997 the american-based institute of
electrical and electronics engineers
or ieee formed a committee that came up
with the technical standard for
transmitting information across these
high radio frequencies
this was the start of what would be
known as wi-fi
just a quick note wi-fi actually doesn't
stand for anything
the name was created by a brand
consulting firm back in 1999
they needed a more catchy name for ieee
802.11
and i think they achieved that
so now the world had a standard for
transmitting information across these
high-frequency waves
but there was still a problem getting
this data to be robust and error-free
was the key to getting wifi to work
properly
this is where the australian scientists
at the csiro come in
[Music]
the csiro works in a whole bunch of
different areas
science chemistry energy exploration and
even mineral sciences
this organization receives a lot of its
funding from the government
they have thousands of scientists
throughout australia
so the road to solving the wi-fi issue
all started when a csiro astrophysicist
john o'sullivan was researching how to
detect black holes the size of an atom
the issue was the radio waves from these
black holes would become distorted as
they traveled to earth
to fix this john used a set of
mathematical equations called fourier
transforms
he adapted them to astronomy to remove
the distortions
a fourier transform can take a signal
and decompose the frequencies that make
up that signal
so that's pretty cool john would never
detect the black holes
but he later realized that his work in
fourier transforms and radio waves could
solve another problem
when the organization was trying to
create a high-speed
wireless network they found that the
radio waves would bounce all around the
room
john coded his fourier transform
equation method of cleaning up signals
into the very logic circuit of the chip
this cleaned up the signals that were
bouncing haphazardly around the room
now instead of bouncing all around the
walls and ceilings and messing up the
signal
the computer on the receiving end could
easily read the signal and understand it
furthermore this chip was small small
enough to fit into a laptop
and also cheap to make the secret to the
chip
was to split the data stream into
hundreds of pieces and then reassemble
them
rapidly the previous state of the art of
this technology would require
a room full of equipment to work the
result of john's chip from the csiro
was greatly improved wi-fi signal
quality it was fast and could transmit a
signal
while reducing echo this happy accident
beat many of the major communications
companies around the world that were
trying to solve the same issue
john o'sullivan explains quote some of
the original seeds were sown in radio
astronomy
curiously it was a failed experiment to
detect exploding mini black holes the
size of an atomic particle
i certainly had no idea where things
would lead
back then we had set out to do a
wireless network at 100 megabits per
second
many people thought we had rocks in our
head to try and do such a thing
we really thought it would be big and
i'm just blown away at how big it has
become
end quote o'sullivan and his team
were not the only ones seeking this
breakthrough but they were the quickest
and best
these patents were filed in 1992 and
it's worth noting that the fundamental
technology for this kind of error
correction has existed and has been used
since the late 1960s when nasa sent the
mariner craft to mars
but making it cheap and in the form of a
small chip was something new
also of note the work that became wi-fi
wouldn't be possible without the
standards agreed upon by the american
electrical engineers association in
1997.
it wouldn't be until 2012 when the
patent was recognized
and the royalties were paid to the csiro
so to answer the question did this
australian government team invent wi-fi
[Music]
not exactly there were many pioneers
before them
but the chip that made it cheap and
feasible was indeed an australian
invention
and it all came from a failed experiment
to detect atomic sized black holes
the more you know huh it's also a great
anecdote for those who say that this
kind of scientific research is pointless
you really just don't know what
technologies can come out of it
anyway thanks for watching i hope you
enjoyed that video or at least found it
interesting
if you're interested in science
technology business or history
feel free to subscribe to this channel
i'm sure you'll find some interesting
stuff on here
all right so my name is tagogo and
you've been watching cold fusion i'll
see you again soon for the next episode
cheers guys have a good one
cold fusion it's me thinking
you